estamos a 5 mujeres para que se
clasificarán a sí mismas según su
atractivo
también invitamos a 5 hombres para que
observaran y reorganizarán la
clasificación
basados en su visión del atractivo
[Música]
podemos decir a qué nos dedicamos cuáles
son muslos piezas futboleras soy
bailarina soy muy física utilizo mucho
mi cuerpo me encanta hornear pasteles
siempre le doy a mis amigos pasteles
enseño actuación a niños pequeños hago
teatro música o dios porque soy una
niñita
pero estoy soltera así que hola soy
estudiante de periodismo también soy
estudiante me estoy especializando en
psicología y justicia penal
también soy actriz me encanta viajar es
todo en la india cinco veces bien
haremos esto nos clasificaremos cerremos
los ojos y nos moveremos a donde creemos
que debemos ir y luego me entendieron
luego compartimos nuestra opinión creo
que es muy interesante que tan atractiva
crees que eres siento que mi
personalidad es atractiva y mi
apariencia
que estoy bien no creo que nadie me mira
y piense
estoy nerviosa ya como no tocaremos
entre nosotras alguien lo pensó lo
siento somos tan humildes estamos como
tú primero y si no sabes cuál es el
número permiso
dios mío punto en el 2 la chica que más
me parece atractiva es jordan tiene una
gran personalidad y segura de sí misma
toma muy mira pensé que esto era me tocó
eres me quedaré eso no es correcto
espera espera espera no es justo que no
no no
como llegué ahí si lo hacemos a partir
de la impresión inmediata sobre la
atracción que generamos solo voy a
decirlo para que continúe en el 1234
los 101
2 3 4 1 2 3 4 en 1 1 2 3 4 bien 1 2 3 4
viene seré 2 porque me tocaron todos los
2 bien creo que tengo tres o cuatro así
que me meteré en esta ventana
dependiendo de las otras personas había
atributos que veían las otras chicas que
yo no veía en mí y por eso los habría
puesto más arriba que a mí las personas
dicen ella es tan dulce es tan divertida
pero no saldría con ella supongo que
seré uno de acuerdo
perfecto ya las aprecio muy bien todavía
si saldría con todas ellas eso me
convierte en un tres de acuerdo sí
hombre que está bien ninguna quería ser
la última y pude percibir esa sensación
así que me dije sabes que está bien
nadie se un cinco realmente entonces
número ciento crees que eres la menos
atractiva
no lo creo pero quiero decir dónde crees
que encajaría mejor aquí bueno no sé
siento que la personalidad es importante
ella es o no no por mucho
2 2 3 gracias bueno
que no tenga personalidad airbag links o
soy 5 otra vez creo que estamos en orden
de las más extrovertidas no de personal
hice esto es definitiva esto es
definitivo
por favor pónganse las orejeras
ah
ahora cinco hombres se harán la
clasificación
de acuerdo con su percepción del
atractivo
que quieres empezar
tú por allá muy bien y luego acomódense
creo que michelle era la más atractiva
su aspecto su forma de comportarse y
parece alguien que va a vivir una vida
emocionante o con la que tendrías una
conversación profunda podría cambiar con
ella
olvide que no pueden oír me tenés que
escribir se tiene que cambiarías yo la
cambiaría a ella y a ella tuve allá a de
acuerdo muy bien si no hay problema
entonces para allá
puedes cambiar si está más o menos
personalmente se parece a kristen bell y
me gusta mucho kristen bell así que
probablemente la pondría en la posición
1 o 2 y me gusta su estilo creo que toda
su estética es muy agradable así que
para mí es un uno o dos aquí creo que
maría es la más atractiva para mí era
todo su aspecto y me gustó cómo estaba
su pelo como estaba maquillada estaba
muy linda nos conformamos con que 55
35 que sean al menos 3 así que el 5 sube
debería ser un 4 porque están en 0 que 4
está bien 5 y 4 también bien hicimos una
clasificación nueva no quiero ser el
verdugo los chicos no tienen miedo a ser
más francos fueron directos oye eres
atractiva tú también tú no lo eres pero
las chicas estaban como no quiero ser
grosera sabes todos somos hermosas a
nuestra manera muy bien estamos bien
está bien damos listos
genial dios eso fue despiadado me sentí
mal
[Música]
sí
por la forma en que nosotros las
clasificamos creo que lo hacíamos sobre
todo por la personalidad yo estaba muy
nervioso por clasificarlas me sudaban
las manos me sentía realmente incómodo
por ser el que las movía donde pensaba
obviamente es algo que hacemos a diario
clasificamos a las personas
inconscientemente pero tener que hacerlo
delante de ellas y que te vean
clasificarlas puede no fue divertido
pero si una experiencia memorable cómo
fue la experiencia en general bueno
estaba en el 5 y ahora estoy como aquí
así que gracias no sé es muy interesante
creo pensé que al entrar en esto los
estereotipos culturales serían un factor
el hecho de que me clasificaron de
primera lo desmiente porque no pensé que
le querían a una chica asiática de
primera creo que pienso que cuando un
hombre me ve eso y poco atractiva pero
para una mujer puede que sí es
definitivamente diferente porque en un
entorno masculino juzgando me sabía que
eso iba a pasar no soy estúpida así que
soy consciente
de cómo me ven los demás me sorprendió
que me colocaran en el último lugar pero
al mismo tiempo sé que en una sala de
chicas hermosas como la que estaba desde
él yo no había ninguna posibilidad para
mí si no había ninguna oportunidad
siendo yo la única chica negra sabía que
realmente no iba a estar más arriba
porque los estándares de belleza
americanos frente a lo que ve la gente
de color es diferente los chicos con los
que me relaciono se rodean más de
mujeres negras y creen que las mujeres
negras son atractivas creo que los
chicos clasificaron a las mujeres más
por su apariencia que por su
personalidad suele sentir que eres la
persona más atractiva de la sala
generalmente sí me parece que solo
confirma que el atractivo es tan
subjetivo y básico y se presenta de una
manera y siempre ha sido así aunque
tengo mis días en los que estoy como un
no eres realmente tan linda hay días en
los que dos tú estás eres muy linda
diría que no cambiaría
no cambiaría
jubilee vive intensamente